Budweiser was the American Beer it took
decades to build that brand and they
blew it up in 30 hours and Target wants
to sell to everybody everybody obviously
and they've made a huge mistake do you
ever hear a CEO of that represents a
company ever talking about abortion
never because that is an issue that will
never be resolved it's a personal issue
it's a family issue it's a religious
issue it's partisan forever you don't
touch it same thing with politics same
thing with gender identity everybody has
a personal opinion about it when you
actually get involved in a fight like
that you lose 50 percent of your
constituency